.
- En 2009, Bernard Lachance
est au sommet de ses belles
années.
(applaudissements)
Il est même accueilli par
Oprah Winfrey, la grande dame
de la télévision américaine.
♪ ♪ ♪
Pendant un bref moment,
il est partout et semble parti
pour la gloire.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais 12 ans plus tard,
sa vie avait pris
une tout autre tournure.
- Tu dois avoir une grosse
surprise en me voyant la face.
Ça va pas très bien dans ma vie.
- Cette vidéo a été filmée
11 jours avant que Bernard
Lachance ne meure à l'âge
de 46 ans.
- J'ai des problèmes de
digestion. Le corps ne garde
rien. Je vomis une pomme.
- Ce message est destiné
à son ami Hugues Holleville,
un ex-médecin français qui offre
des soins non conventionnels.
HUGUES HOLLEVILLE, ex-médecin
- Le scoop, c'est que
de mon point de vue,
les virus n'existent pas.
- Reviens-moi, Hugues,
il faut que tu me sauves la vie.
- En réponse à l'appel à l'aide
de Bernard Lachance,
Hugues Holleville lui conseille
de boire trois litres d'eau
salée par jour, en l'assurant
que ce régime allait rétablir
son système digestif.
- Moi, je dis que
les scientifiques qui disent que
le VIH ne cause pas le sida
ont tout à fait raison.
J'en suis une preuve vivante.
- Bernard Lachance était
séropositif, mais il n'avait
plus confiance dans la médecine
moderne.
- À la grande déception
de l'empire politico-
pharmaceutique...
- En 2017, il avait cessé
sa trithérapie, ce protocole
pharmaceutique qui donne
aux personnes séropositives
une espérance de vie
presque normale.
- Au total, ça aura coûté
120 000 $ aux contribuables,
parce qu'on nous vend pas ça
5 piastres, ces petites
pilules-là!
- Mais quelques années
plus tard...
- Bernard est en train
de mourir. Ah non!
La mort, elle n'existe pas.
- Sa mort est l'aboutissement
de quelques années qui
vont bouleverser son entourage,
un parcours qui l'a plongé dans
l'univers des complotistes.
- Et Mesdames et Messieurs,
Bernard Lachance, qui
lui aussi s'est converti
dans le conspirationnisme
et le complotisme.
- C'est en 2017 que Bernard
Lachance commence à s'intéresser
à des personnages controversés.
GUYLAINE LANCTÔT, ex-médecin
- Est-ce qu'il y en a qui
croient encore que le sida
est contagieux? C'est la plus
grande imposture du siècle!
- Guylaine Lanctôt est
très connue dans le milieu
de la médecine alternative.
Cette médecin déchue ne croit
pas à la pandémie de la COVID,
ni au VIH, ni aux vaccins.
- C'est pas vrai qu'on a besoin
de manger et de boire
pour survivre.
- Quelques mois après
avoir découvert les théories
de Guylaine Lanctôt, Bernard
Lachance arrête sa trithérapie.
- Non seulement je lui ai parlé,
mais c'est une dame que j'adore,
c'est une amie. Elle me
racontait... J'ai dit : Comment
t'as entendu parler de ça,
la fraude HIV?
- Pendant la pandémie, Bernard
Lachance devient une vedette
du monde conspirationniste, avec
des propos qui font souvent écho
à ceux de Guylaine Lanctôt.
- Le VIH n'a jamais été isolé
et démontré dans le sang
de personnes qui ont un test
qu'on dit positif.
- Moi, qui "est" supposé,
d'après l'OMS et Big Pharma,
d'avoir 2 milliards de virus
dans mon sang, on peut pas
m'en montrer un.
MARIE-CLAUDE LACHANCE,
soeur de Bernard Lachance
- Ah! il est-tu beau...
Tête de cochon!
- Plusieurs proches du chanteur,
dont ses soeurs, nous racontent
avoir dû couper les ponts,
car sa nouvelle obsession
prenait toute la place.
- Quand il est tombé là-dedans,
il ne parlait que de ça?
- Que de ça!
Il se nourrissait de fausses
informations. Moi, j'ai...
J'ai la certitude que Bernard
s'est fait manipuler.
- Pendant ses derniers mois,
Bernand Lachance ne se sentait
pas bien. Il avait tenté de
se soigner à l'aide de divers
produits naturels qui
lui avaient été recommandés
par son amie Amélie Paul.
- Aujourd'hui, on parle de
censure dans les médias.
- Chanteuse et youtubeuse,
Amélie Paul se dit aussi
naturopathe.  Elle est également
représentante de ventes pour une
marque de produits naturels sur
laquelle Bernard Lachance avait
dépensé des milliers de dollars.
Dr MICHEL MARTEL, médecin
et ami de Bernard Lachance
- Il disait qu'il faisait
un traitement naturel avec de
l'eau salée, des électrolytes,
pour traiter sa condition
actuelle, sa diarrhée,
sa perte de poids. Et aussi,
il avait un autre but,
c'était de faire un genre de
désintoxication des médicaments
qu'il avait pris il y a
trois ans et demi, quatre ans,
les médicaments contre le sida.
- Michel Martel était un ami de
longue date de Bernard Lachance.
Médecin, il avait lui aussi
pris ses distances depuis
quelques année.
Il lui a rendu visite
11 jours avant son décès.
- Je trouve ça phénoménal,
phénoménal que ces gens-là
le voyaient en FaceTime,
puis qu'ils lui disaient :
"Non, non, c'est pas grave,
je vais te donner
des médicaments naturels."
Dr RÉJEAN THOMAS, PDG fondateur
Clinique médicale l'Actuel
- Bien, c'est triste,
c'est triste parce que c'est
complètement... Je veux dire,
je cherche le mot.... profiter,
profiter des gens et derrière ça
normalement, il y a des sous.
- Réjean Thomas est une sommité
dans le domaine du VIH.
C'est aussi l'ancien médecin
de Bernard Lachance.
- Ils l'ont vu mourir,
ils l'ont vu dépérir, et de
continuer, et de purger des gens
et de faire boire de l'eau salée
et des choses comme ça...
Si Bernard avait pris
son traitement, il serait
encore ici. C'est surtout ça
la question : Pourquoi Bernard
est allé vers chez gens-là au
lieu de venir vers la science?
- Pourquoi?
- C'est une question
à poser à un psychiatre.
- Dans un courriel,
Hugues Holleville a affirmé
qu'il n'avait offert que
des conseils gratuits à
son ami Bernard Lachance et que
ce dernier n'aurait jamais
accepté d'être hospitalisé.
Amélie Paul n'a pas donné suite
à notre demande d'entrevue,
mais dans une vidéo, elle dit
que Bernard Lachance était
inébranlable.
AMÉLIE PAUL
- Mais personne aurait pu lui
dire quoi faire. C'est un gars
intelligent.
- Guylaine Lanctôt n'a pas
répondu à nos questions.
Quelques jours après notre
premier courriel, elle a filmé
cette vidéo :
- On va dire que c'est suspect,
la manière dont il est mort.
- Oui, oui. Il était en grande
forme et en trois mois,
il a dégringolé à toute vitesse.
LISE LACHANCE,
soeur de Bernard Lachance
- Bernard avait peur.
Il était comme dans une folie.
Il avait peur que le
gouvernement ou le Big Pharma
se débarrassent de lui.
Il avait peur de ça.
Il ne se rendait pas compte que
ceux de qui il aurait dû avoir
peur, c'est ceux qu'il appelait
à l'aide.